[Musik]
mikus wie ein fach deutsch lernen was
ist nicos weg der online sprachkurs
nicos weg vermittelt grammatik und
lerninhalte in insgesamt 228 kurzfilmen
das besondere ist dass dieser kurs
wirklich alles in sich vereint er hat
eine spannende geschichte in form einer
video novela er hat interaktive übungen
erst mobil verfügbar ist online
verfügbar er hat 230 lektionen mit denen
ich von a bis z lernen kann und er ist
kostenlos wer ist nico
der 22 jährige spanier nico hat sein
studium abgebrochen und kommt nach
deutschland
das im prinzip geht es darum dass man
mit mir gemeinsam lernt in deutschland
anzukommen und die sprache zu lernen mit
alltagsproblemen und sorgen die jeder
hat und wir erkennen worum geht es in
der geschichte
am flughafen lernt nico eine studentin
und ihre nichte kennen als er seine
tasche verliert nehmen ihn die beiden
vorübergehend bei sich auf hier lernt
nico den typisch deutschen alltag kennen
mit mülltrennung in der wohngemeinschaft
welche elemente bietet der kurs alle
videos haben untertitel die man nach
bedarf ein- oder abschalten karosserie
wunder hallo lisa wie geht es dir
passend zu den kurzvideos gibt es über
14.000 sprachübungen welche niveaustufen
deckt der kurs ab der kurs nicos weg hat
drei teile von a1 bis b 1 auf a 1 und a
2 gibt es bilinguale übungs anweisungen
die stufe b1 ist mono lingua mit dem
einstufungstest kann man seine
deutschkenntnisse testen wo und wie kann
ich den kurs nutzen
was ist also sehr guten diesem programm
finde das sehr praktisch und kann gar
nicht also dieses programm benutzen
überall und irgendwann eine arbeitspause
auf meinem weg oder in welchen kontrast
sprachen gibt es den kurs
nicos weg gibt es in mehreren kontrast
sprachen neben englisch spanisch oder
französisch sind es zum beispiel auch
eine arabische persische oder
chinesische version
wo finde ich den kurs nicos weg
den kurs kann man mobil nutzen über die
app dw jörn german oder unter jörn
german punkt db.com über die
desktop-version am pc
zu den lektionen gelangt man über die
startseite jede niveaustufe hat 18
thematische einheiten jede einheit hat
vier lektionen
am ende jeder niveaustufe gibt es einen
interaktiven abschlusstest
wie sieht eine lektion aus
den aufbau der lektionen können wir uns
am beispiel der lektion 81 nico hat ein
problem anschauen
jede lektion beginnt mit einer
übersichtsseite
sie enthält das video und die übersicht
der lerninhalte post wunder hallo lisa
wie geht's dir was ist los
doch keine sorge immer geht es gut aber
nico hat ein problem er war auch am
flughafen er kommt aus spanien
ja genau er kommt aus spanien und der
hat ein problem seine tasche ist weg und
er spricht gut deutsch hat er papiere
eine auswahl
hast du einen pass
nein - pass ist in seiner tasche
aber er hat ein foto von seiner tante
sie wohnt auch hier in deutschland aber
nico hat die adresse nicht meine tante
stickel show seine tanz hat ein geschäft
ein charakter wir suchen also eine
adresse die frau sarah farag okay dann
kommt noch mit nico zur polizei danke
papa gerne später später und vielleicht
kann mein vater uns helfen
er hilft
was gut lief
ich schaue immer wieder frei
[Musik]
zu jeder lektion gibt es rund zehn
interaktive übungen mit auswertung
man kann jede übung wiederholen oder
sich die richtige lösung anzeigen lassen
nico kommt aus spanien
er war am flughafen er spricht nicht gut
deutsch er hat ein problem
richtig grün falls rot das ist nico er
kommt aus spanien
das ist ja sie wohnt in deutschland das
ist emma sie kommt aus deutschland
nico hast du einen pass ja ich habe
einen pass aber der passt ist weg hallo
lisa und nico habt ihr ein problem
ja wir haben ein problem
nicos pass ist weg hat lisa ein telefon
ja sie hat ein telefon haben lisa und
emma die adresse von jahre
nein sie haben die adresse nicht nach
dem durchlaufen aller übungen einer
lektion bekommt man das erreichte übungs
ergebnis angezeigt wenn man eingeloggt
ist kann man sein ergebnis speichern
an dieser stelle hat man auch die
möglichkeit sein ergebnis zu verbessern
oder noch einmal zu üben
wo findet man begleitmaterialien zur
lektion
antwort im lektion menü orangefarbige
arbeiten hier findet man die grammatik
übersicht zur lektion
alle vokabeln der lektion sind vertont
das auto
die autos
zu jeder lektion gibt es eine kurze
landeskundliche information in der
kontrast sprache im manuskript kann man
sich bei markierten vokabeln deren
übersetzung anzeigen lassen und sie
anhören das foto
die fotos
unter extras findet man download
möglichkeiten für dokumente und medien
der lektion
lehrer finden hier unterrichts tipps zur
lektion und drei übungen als pdf zum
ausdrucken
ebenfalls findet man hier den link zum
arbeitsbuch vor nicos weg mit
kopiervorlagen für kreative spiele und
aufgaben
[Musik]
über das orangefarbene lektion menü kann
man auch alle übungen zurücksetzen
über den button kurs übersicht gelangt
man wieder zurück zu den lektionen
um die niveaustufe oder die sprache zu
wechseln navigiert man über den blauen
balken über die übergeordnete kurs
navigation hier findet man außerdem eine
globale grammatik übersicht und stehen
gesamten vertonten wortschatz mit
suchfunktion
über das blaue kurs menü findet man auch
den bereich hilfe und den weg zur
anmeldung
für alle fans von niko gibt es auf
youtube alle folgen der drei
niveaustufen als ganzen film drei mal
anderthalb stunden nie pur viel spaß und
erfolg mit nikons weg
[Musik]